by doing this food strike --
we could have gone to jail.
But, hey, it worked.
Twenty-four hours later,
we were picked up from school
and escorted to the office of the governor.
MW: And there he was --
(Applause)
waiting for us to meet and speak,
being all supportive and thankful for our willingness
to care for the beauty and the environment of Bali.
He signed a promise
to help the people of Bali say no to plastic bags.
And we are now friends,
and on a regular basis,
we remind him and his team of the promises he has made.
And indeed,
recently he stated and committed
that Bali will be plastic bag free by 2018.
(Applause)
IW: Also, at the International Airport of Bali, one of our supporters
is planning to start a plastic bag-free policy by 2016.
MW: Stop handing out free plastic bags
and bring in your own reusable bag
is our next message to change that mindset of the public.
IW: Our short-term campaign,
"One Island / One Voice,"
is all about this.
We check and recognize the shops and restaurants
that have declared themselves a plastic bag-free zone,
and we put this sticker at their entrance
and publish their names on social media
and some important magazines on Bali.
And conversely,
that highlights those who do not have the sticker.
(Laughter)
MW: So, why are we actually telling you all of this?
Well, partly, it is because we are proud
of the results that, together with our team,
we have been able to reach.
But also because along the way,
we have learned that kids can do things.
We can make things happen.
Isabel and I were only 10 and 12 years old
when we started this.
We never had a business plan,
nor a fixed strategy,
nor any hidden agendas --
just the idea in front of us
and a group of friends working with us.
All we wanted to do was stop those plastic bags
from wrapping and suffocating our beautiful home.
Kids have a boundless energy
and a motivation to be the change the world needs.
IW: So to all the kids of this beautiful but challenging world:
go for it!
Make that difference.
We're not telling you it's going to be easy.
We're telling you it's going to be worth it.
Us kids may only be 25 percent of the world's population,
but we are 100 percent of the future.
MW: We still have a lot of work to do,
but know that we still not stop
until the first question asked when arriving at the Bali airports will be
Both: "Welcome to Bali,
do you have nay plastic bags to declare?"
(Laughter)
Om shanti shanti shanti om.
Thank you.
(Applause)